I was speaking to a law enforcement
officer he came home from a bad day at
work and left his gun upon the kitchen
table and when using the I room he fell
asleep and his kid found the gun
his wife was able to intervene and take
the fire him away from his kid and so
nothing happened but let's say his wife
hadn't been home that could have been a
very very bad situation if that had been
a smart gun it would have been different
with a smart gun the kid finds the gun
it's gonna be locked
[Applause]
Americans have never been more
politically engaged on the issue of gun
violence and yet attempts at widespread
gun control laws keep hitting a brick
wall as the gun debate rages on some are
considering a different kind of solution
one that could have a huge impact on
certain kinds of gun violence a smart
gun is a gun that can only be used by
the owner either because of biometrics
that is finger print or some other
technology smart cons could prevent
thousands of suicides let's start there
now if a teenager wants to kill himself
and the easiest means is their father or
mother's gun they're unable to do that
it wouldn't stop all mass shootings but
it would stop some of them because so
often in mass shootings the young man is
using a gun that isn't actually theirs
so smart guns could have a profound
effect in terms of gun safety in America
my name is Kai Klopfer I'm the founder
of bio fire technologies an early-stage
startup based here in Boston basically
what we're doing is incorporating
fingerprint sensors or other
authentication methods into firearms our
prototype as far as I know it's the
first fingerprints mark on in the world
so we've got our live fire prototype
here what this is is we've taken an
off-the-shelf firearm and incorporated
all of our technology into it so this is
my teammate Luke we've got this here
it's programmed to me and so if I hand
it to you here I'm good and you put your
finger on the sensor here it's just
gonna flash white so no matter how much
he pulls on the trigger it's just gonna
be completely locked but if I take it
and do the exact same thing it's gonna
go red and what that means that if I
close the slide jerk it's gonna fire
I've been involved in the smart gun
space for about six years now I
originally got into it as a sophomore in
high school I thought of course mark
guns are gonna work like I understand
the technology and I've shot guns and
I've used guns in the past there's no
reason why we shouldn't be able to mine
these right it turns out that at the
time if I talked to pretty much anybody
most people would have probably told me
that was impossible
there is no smart gun available in the
United States today because Second
Amendment absolutists are effeminately
opposed to smart guns a safe gun is one
that fires when you pull the trigger
every single time if tech companies
can't make electronics that are 100%
reliable
how are firearms companies supposed to
do it when you need a firearm there is
ZERO time to be messing with rebooting
your gun the government could turn these
things off they could be like well
there's a natural disaster in Florida
let's turn all the guns off for a while
for their own protection as if this
basic level of mistrust weren't enough
one state's attempt to mandate smart gun
technology has made things even worse
there's a law that's passed in New
Jersey it's called the childproof
handgun act that says that in New Jersey
once a smart gun is available anywhere
the United States all guns sold in New
Jersey after a certain time period have
to be smart guns so if you try to sell a
fireman say Texas a smart gun that is
going to trigger the New Jersey law
what that did was anytime that somebody
has thought about selling a smart gun
anywhere in the United States there's
been some pushback there are several
instances in recent years where a store
had decided that they were going to
carry a smart gun from Europe and
because of New Jersey the store owner
received so many threats of violence
against him that he decided not to carry
the smart gun
so basically mob violence has kept spark
guns off the market New Jersey everybody
involved including the state senators
that initially introduced the bill have
realized that it didn't quite work the
way they were intended so that law is in
the final stages of being repealed that
is on its way out the door this
technology can only have impact if
people are choosing to buy it instead of
traditional firearms we would much
rather have the opportunity to get this
out there improved people that it's a
superior product that people want to buy
all right well we're about to do a live
fire demo here you can see if I put my
finger on it it's gonna go red and then
when I come up here to fire
and that's what we're all there is to it
Khai still faces a lot of challenges
many potential buyers could be put off
by the unreliability of fingerprint
readers under wet or dirty conditions
and past attempts at smart guns have
been unaffordable for most buyers
because of the high-tech electronics
involved
but if his startup can get a smart gun
on the market it just might inspire
bigger gun companies to do the same the
gun industry is in a slump now a
terrible slump the great irony of course
is that the president Donald Trump is a
big gun supporter and that's the reason
so many fewer guns are being sold
because gun owners aren't afraid anymore
that someone's gonna take their gun away
so one really strong reason for getting
a smart gun on the market is that it's a
new technology and it's a new product I
think it's inevitable that smart guns
will take their place alongside not
smart guns in America
actually solving gun violence is gonna
be a big task you know this is not
something that can be solved just by
smart guns but I think that technology
has a role of play if I can even save
one life I think that's worth it at the
end of the day and this honestly has the
opportunity to save a lot more than that
you
you